j'adore wikipédia les puristes diront
que c'est un parfait mais franchement
ils font la fine bouche après tout
certaines études suggèrent que wikipedia
est désormais l'encyclopédie la plus
fiable au monde
mais en plus d'être fiable wikipedia est
aussi extrêmement complet à tel point
qu'il est devenu extrêmement courant
pour des chercheurs à la pointe de leur
domaine de s'informer sur wikipédia en
tout cas en maths et en informatique
je pense personnellement qu'on ne prend
pas suffisamment le temps de s'extasier
devant wikipédia je veux dire en l'an
2000 je réparais mais alors sans
problème contre le succès d'une
encyclopédie gratuite écrite et édité
par des anonymes non rémunéré d'autant
que quand on y réfléchit
le pouvoir d'édicter ukip et dia est
énorme
par exemple pendant l'élection
présidentielle wikipedia liste est des
résultats de sondages
or choisir les sondages a publié peu
affecté ce que l'on croit des intentions
de vote des électeurs ce qui peut
ensuite affecté l'issue du vote tout ça
parce qu'on utilise un scrutin
uninominal à deux tours qui a la
mauvaise propriété de nous exposer au
10ème du vote utile
de même ce que wikipedia dit de la
vaccination du réchauffement climatique
ou des ogm peut grandement affecté le
comportement des citoyens
l'opinion publique et donc les décisions
politiques et tout ça ça pose la
question comment wikipédia et il pu
conserver sa fiabilité pour essayer de
comprendre comment occuper dia arrive à
fonctionner j'ai squatté une wii qui
rencontre à genève où j'ai rencontré
adrien doctorat en astrophysique à
l'observatoire de genève et milan depuis
5-6 ans bao des recherches at war
formation et j'avais commencé quelques
petites modifications loger des frais de
retour chose puis petit à petit j'ai
commencé à participer
et voilà un ou deux ans j'ai créé un
compte
depuis j'ai créé quelques centaines dans
la classe c grâce à des bénévoles comme
adrien que wikipédia a pu s'enrichir
d'articles en quantité et que ces
articles ont ensuite pu gagner en
qualité et comme d'autres wikipédiens
très actif
adrien est ensuite devenu administrateur
du wikipédia administrateurs après ouais
la poste sur tout pour renommer des
articles quand une bonne raison dormi
mais aussi pour supprimer les
vandalismes à le vandalisme sur
wikipédia jours de trek il faut censurer
bon il ya plusieurs types de vandalisme
ya les vandalismes lippi cacao
des gens mais juste des phrases et
demandez lui même article ja après ils
vont réalisme sur noah qui sont plus
embêtant ce vent juste pas un article
dévalant numérique et on va juste
légèrement changé la valeur 100 m 2 sont
sans rien et c'est le genre de
modifications qui a priori est difficile
à savoir c'est s'il est correct ou pas
mais ce sont les plus difficiles à
détecter
mais comment faire pour repérer les
vandalismes dans tous équipés dia jeux
suivront en direct les modifications des
articles et à près de 60 toutes les
modifications sont enregistrés dans
l'existant avec des articles donc il ya
toujours moyen si on repère organismes
de l'est les supprimer après coup mais
alors généralement s'exprimer rapidement
malheureusement ça arrive qu'il y en ait
qui reste sur moi ça doit prendre un
temps fou
puis à quelques années j'étais beaucoup
plus présent maintenant je suis moins
quelques heures par semaine et ça c'est
représentatif d'un administrateur
wikipédia bon je pense que c'est assez
variable soit on n'a pas de
je tâche imposée on va dire chacun
participe comme il a envie d'un certain
qu'ils pas a priori partie beaucoup plus
mais du coup et vous qui paie bien ce qu
en est-il entre eux oui alors je connais
pas vraiment leur tel mais toi qui as d
iliad est ce nouveau
quand on voit très régulièrement il ya
des noms qui souvent c'est des
administrateurs ou pas comme
administrateur mais aussi d'autres
contributeurs
très régulier je pense notamment aux
astronomes
donc là il ya un petit groupe de
contributeurs réguliers sur cette meuf
mais alors si n'y a qu'un petit groupe
comme dans tout petits groupes
la réputation des contributeurs ne
va-t-elle pas affecté d'une certaine
manière le pouvoir d'édition des
contributeurs damman qu'on aime auteurs
connus on sait plus bien du travail
généralement bas il va pas s'amuser à
contrôler toute modification on nous
fait confiance quand c'est les nouveaux
contributeurs ou encore les utilisateurs
si vous adresse ip donc pas de comptes
enregistrés carrément va être beaucoup
plus méfiant de ski mais après ça peut
aussi avoir un effet pervers qui si on
fait confiance à quelqu un bel
appartement contrôler ce qui met est de
dire on n'est pas infaillible
si on fait une erreur et va être là et
il ya peut-être moins de personnes qui
vont contrôler corriger si son client
et est ce que ça serait assez juste que
de dire que le pouvoir d'édition sur
wikipédia les fonctions de la réputation
je pense oui
en fait je pense qu'il n'est pas trop
farfelue que de dire que wikipedia est
et piste aux pratiques comme on l'a vu
dans l'épisode 30 les pistes au cra si
aussi appelé j'ai découvert ça la
semaine dernière et pis démocratie est
une alternative à la démocratie et à la
dictature qui signifie littéralement le
pouvoir au savoir pour gagner le pouvoir
d'expression sur wikipédia il est
primordial de démontrer une maîtrise
préalable du sujet dont on parle
typiquement en fournissant des sources
de qualité ou d'avoir gagné une
réputation grâce à la qualité d'un
travail passé et ça c'est finalement une
bonne façon d'accorder un pouvoir
d'édition proportionnelle aux savoirs du
contributeur en particulier à l'instar
d'ailleurs du monde académique wikipédia
n'est pas démocratique dans la mesure où
l'article final dépendra bien plus de l'
expertise des contributeurs que de
l'avis de la majorité des contributeurs
alors pour finir cette vidéo j'aimerais
insister sur un principe clé de l'épi
stockera si wikipédienne qui est aussi
un principe clé de l'épi stockera six
scientifiques et qui me semble largement
transposable au monde politique en
france pour des raisons historiques
notamment suite aux oeuvres de
montesquieu où on parle beaucoup du
principe de séparation des pouvoirs
j'aimerais introduire un autre principe
qui je pense est plus important que la
séparation des pouvoirs
c'est ce que je vais appeler le principe
de séparation des expertises
ce principe est devenu fondamental dans
le monde de la recherche académique
ce n'est pas parce que intel a gagné un
prix nobel en économie que son avis sur
la bonne interprétation de la mécanique
quantique à une quelconque valeur pour
que ce prix nobel est ce mot à dire sur
la mécanique quantique
il faudra d'abord démontrer son
expertise en mécanique quantique de même
l'interview d'adrien suggère que son
pouvoir d'édition en astrophysique est
bien plus important que son pouvoir
d'édition dans d'autres disciplines
malheureusement de nos jours la
politique telle qu'elle est aujourd'hui
semble constamment violés ce principe de
séparation des expertises tous citoyens
et politiciens semblent avoir un mot à
dire voir semble devoir avoir un mot à
dire surtout plein de sujets requérant
pourtant des expertises très différentes
pire encore si on s'intéresse beaucoup à
la politique on a de bonnes chances de
tomber dans l'un des camps politiques et
à défendre de manière hooligans toutes
les positions de notre camp politique
on l'a vu à cause des scrutins que l'on
utilise des pisteurs bubble et des
éternuements viraux nos démocraties
divise favorise la polarisation des
idées et la défense hooligans des
valeurs sacrées au nôtre et du coup si
un citoyen veut voter pour la
redistribution des richesses et pour des
mesures économiques davantage libéral
tout en voulant combattre les émissions
de gaz à effet de serre en investissant
notamment massivement dans la recherche
sur les ogm il a de bonnes chances de
pas savoir que faire tout ça parce que
nos démocraties viole constamment le
principe de séparation des expertises et
ça c'est peut-être au final la plus
grosse différence entre wikipédia et nos
démocraties l'avait informé que j'avais
donnée cet argument contre la démocratie
y en a plusieurs par evo qui ont du coup
demandé ce qu est l alternative
qu est-ce que vraiment les pistes au cra
si vous imaginez peut-être que je vais
vous proposer une solution toute faite
alternative non c'est pas du tout ça en
fait les pistes au cra si c'est juste un
principe cessé de donner plus de parole
plus de voix à des personnes qui ont
plus de connaissances ont meilleure
maîtrise des questions au sujet desquels
on essaie de prendre des décisions et ça
ça arrive tout le temps notamment il ya
l'excellent documentaire de hbo bulli
qui montre que en tout cas dans le
domaine artistique souvent les prix sont
décernés par des experts du domaine et
du coup la décision d'attribuer un prix
à quelqu'un n'est absolument pas
démocratique
elle est et piste aux pratiques bulli
part du domaine artistique mais aussi
plein d'autres exemples
par exemple le ballon d'or en football
est désigné en grande partie par des
experts du domaine que ce soit des
anciens joueurs des entraîneurs ou des
journalistes et de la même façon puisque
c'est d'actualité
les prix nobel sont décernés par un
comité d'experts et vaut sans doute
mieux que ça soit le cas
plutôt que ce soit via un vote
démocratique pas mal d'autres parmi vous
souligner que finalement les experts
sont finalement aussi biaisés et puis
ils ont leurs propres intérêts ils
coulent les pistes krassine ne va pas
prendre des décisions qui sont optimales
pour toute la société
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec ça et
je ne suis pas personnellement un énorme
défenseur de l'épi stockera si c'est pas
alors les pistes oak racing ou rien
on skype et stockera ci a beaucoup de
défauts et d'ailleurs c'est également ce
qu'affirme john brennan dans son livre
games démocratie tout ce qu'il dit et je
suis assez d'accord avec lui c'est qu'il
ya sans doute énormément de cas où la
décision et piste aux pratiques donnera
finalement nos meilleurs résultats avec
une décision démocratique et en
particulier il faut voir les pistes au
cra si non pas comme une solution
miracle idéal qui complètement désirable
et qui est un but vers lequel il faut
tendre
non pas du tout selon john brennan ne
suis pas mal d'accord avec lui encore
une fois il faut voir les pistes au
crasy comme un marteau et peut-être que
le marteau calé les pistes au cra ci
sera plus utile il sera meilleur que le
marteau qu'est la démocratie donc selon
brennan il faut pas attribuer une valeur
intrinsèque au système politique mais il
faut le juger en fonction des
conséquences auxquelles il conduit ça
correspond conséquentialiste mme
elle parlait dans la vidéo sur la chaîne
de monsieur fils adrien valette nous
demandent comment reconnaître les
experts comment les sélectionnés d'une
certaine manière
alors il ya énormément de façon de faire
et notamment façon ou qui paie diène en
s'appuyant notamment pas mal sur la
réputation des différents contributeurs
est une solution c'est aussi la solution
privilégiée par le monde académique qui
repose aussi sur des mesures comme leur
agenda etc c'est tout qui sont très
critiquables et très critiqué mais
encore une fois je suis pas en train de
chercher un système parfait de recherche
un système qui est juste meilleur que le
système politique démocratique que l'on
a aujourd'hui dont brennan propose
plusieurs implémentations de bespoke
racines dans son livre par exemple une
façon de faire ce serait de proposer un
examen national et la note à l'examen
correspondrait au pouvoir de bottes au
moment d'une décision politique
alors bien sûr dit comme ça on envie de
dire que bah du coup ça va discriminer
les gens ça va encore favoriser l'élite
une façon de contrer cela c'est de
proposer des formations pour résoudre
l'examen mettre en place des préparation
à l'examen
bref en gros ça revient à repenser
l'école et l'éducation
bref on en revient au problème
fondamental qu'est l'éducation
et oui je pense que pour prendre les
dispositions politiques il vaut mieux
une meilleure éducation une autre
solution au plus sophistiqué c'est de
laisser tout le monde voter et utilisez
ensuite peut être des modèles
mathématiques permet de prédire à partir
de la manière dont quelqu'un a voté ce
qu'il aurait voté
s'il avait été plus informés il ya des
façons au désistement pour faire des
modèles mathématiques qui essaient de
prédire sa et du coup chacun on va être
toujours son pouvoir d'expression mais
son pouvoir d'expression sera ensuite ré
interpréter
et on corrigerait en fait son ignorance
en imaginant ce qu'ils auraient voté
s'il avait fait l'effort de davantage de
fléchir aux questions très honnêtement
en fait j'ai tendance à être contre
toutes ces approches
parce que je pense qu'il est quelque
chose de très important qui est le
capital moral j'ai eu je vais te ra et
et je vous renvoie vers la vidéo
26 je pense qu'il ya vraiment un énorme
capital moral autour du fait qu'on
utilise un système qui est démocratique
qui a tous les défauts qu'on a mais
auquel on a attaché et c'est important
puisque ça permet notamment de fédérer
un peu les différents citoyens donc ce
capital moral je pense qu'il est très
important c'est pour ça que je serai pas
pour changer la vème république le
président je serais trop bas par contre
je pense vraiment que le principe de
séparation des expertises est quelque
chose de très important je pense que le
choix d'un président ne devrait par
exemple pas remettre en question tous
les efforts qui ont été faits sur par
exemple changement du programme scolaire
au cours des cinq dernières années
le fait de changer tous les cinq ans la
direction vers laquelle on s'en va de
cet effort de changement du programme
scolaire fait que finalement il n'y a
pas de continuité les professeurs sont
perdus et tout ça donc là c'est
typiquement un exemple où je pense que
l' expertise sur qu'est ce qu'un bon
enseignement doit être séparée de
d'autres questions politiques est ce que
je dis là sur l'éducation
en fait ça s'applique en fait à pas mal
de domaines pareil dans le monde de
l'énergie ne peut pas changer de
direction stratégique sur l'énergie
tous les cinq ans et le fait en plus que
ces changements sont démocratiques fait
que on va sans doute pas prendre en
compte ce qui a été fait dans les cinq
années précédentes puisque souvent
l'électeur médian et ignorant de ce qui
a été fait dans les cinq années
précédentes donc en bref je sais pas du
tout pour chambouler tout le système
le capital moral c'est super important
faut pas le perdre mais je serais pour
que
représentants élus par le peuple est
moins leur mot à dire sur des sujets qui
inquiète vraiment de l'expertisé si j'ai
la position que j'ai aujourd'hui
c'est en vertu de mon calcul des
conséquences que cela pourrait engendrer
donc c'est un raisonnement très
conséquentialiste et en particulier si
vous voulez le remettre en cause
il suffit de remettre en cause le fait
qu' un tel changement de politiques
conduisent à de meilleurs conséquences
si vous avez des arguments pour dire que
non ça conduire à de pires conséquences
ben là vous mourrez fait changer d'avis
coach partie sort un argument de
mesquita contre les pistes au cra si ce
qui est très bien vu de sa part en effet
ce que souligne mais ce qu'il faut c'est
que quand le pouvoir est concentré en
très peu de gens alors il y aura
beaucoup plus de risques de corruption
et en particulier les décisions seront
moins favorables à l'ensemble du peuple
il y aura plus d'égoïsme
alors j'aimerais dire que pour certaines
décisions le risque de corruption est
finalement assez faible 7 bat si grave
qui est finalement peu de gens qui se
prennent ce genre de décisions
en revanche rien des décisions ou le
risque de corruption est plus grand
c'est peut être intéressant de faire un
vote quittant un peu plus vers la
démocratie c'est-à-dire où il y aurait
plus d'experts on n'accepte plus de gens
en tant qu'expert est typiquement si on
fait voter des milliers ou des centaines
de milliers de personnes
des centaines de milliers ça reste moins
de 1% du peuple oncle pour cent le plus
informé ça serait quand même beaucoup
plus et piste aux pratiques que le vote
démocratique et elle qui est aujourd'hui
si on fait ça le risque de corruption
devient finalement assez faible
marc-henri chancerel propose de
d'inciter les gens à ne pas voter quand
ils pensent qu'ils ne sont pas
suffisamment informés et ça c'est
typiquement une des grandes propositions
de gsm brennan en fait il est surtout
contre le fait que l'on pousse les gens
à aller voter
même lorsqu'ils ne sont pas informés ou
ne s'intéresse pas à la question est là
vous imaginez bien que le fait que l'on
puisse pousser les gens à aller voter
va encourager tout le système
militantiste est notamment favorisée
l'hooliganisme politique puisque à ce
moment là ce sont le coq le parti qui va
gagner c'est celui qui va avoir réussi à
influencer un maximum de gens et pour
influencer leur maximum de gens et il
vaut mieux être
yann et créer des convictions qui se
propage de manière virale est donc un
corollaire immédiat de la vidéo
précédente c'est que constamment inviter
les gens à aller voter finalement c'est
pas forcément une bonne chose voir ça
peut être considérée comme une mauvaise
chose une chose qui a de mauvaises
conséquences conducteur si on prend un
point de vue séquentiel est bien sûr le
problème c'est que ça va à l'encontre
d'un idéal démocratique qu'on a tous en
tête août on doit aller voter donc après
les élections il ya souvent des gens qui
vont se plaindre du haut taux
d'abstention est finalement l'abstention
ce n'est peut-être pas un si mauvais mal
c'est peut-être même un signe que les
choses vont finalement assez bien
robespierre n'accepte pour réduire
l'hooliganisme propose de tirer au sort
des citoyens au hasard et ses citoyens
de viendront en fait les politiciens
donc ça c'est un exemple de tout ce
mouvement de démocratie participative ou
délibérative qui a énormément de
variantes de ceux de cette idée et c'est
un peu difficile d'ailleurs de donner
billets entre toutes ses variantes
je vous recommande notamment une
excellente vidéo de politiken qui parle
de la démocratie délibérative où l'idée
c'est que on va pas juste beauté on va
aussi avoir des délibérations entre
citoyens et décisions seront issus de
ses délibérations
il ya aussi eu des propositions et des
expériences de démocratie participative
des citoyens tirés au hasard sont amenés
à prendre des décisions collectives et
un à plusieurs parmi vous qui pensent
que les arguments de la vidéo précédente
ne s'applique pas à cette démocratie
en fait si je pense que tout les
arguments de la vidéo précédente
s'applique à des démocraties
participatives peut-être pas la première
ou si on essaie d'avoir un consensus
plutôt que l'a8 une majorité à ce moment
là le premier argument des vidéos
précédent tombe mais on peut rajouter
d'autres arguments contre c'est
démocratie participative notamment ainsi
il y à des libérations dia délibération
de mauvaises propriété en pratique
notamment il ya l'effet de polarisation
de groupe
dont on avait parlé dans l'épisode 10
pour ceux qui veulent en savoir plus
ironique c'est un article de sam stein à
ce sujet tom qui dit délibérations des
jurys dans des procès et on voit que ce
genre de délibérations d'un favorise
très clairement les plus extravertis
ceux qui ont des avis plus tranché
et en plus il ya cet effet deux
phénomènes de groupe qui conduit à
l'extrémisme donc au lieu que ce soit
les minorités qui n'est pas de pouvoir
en finale ça va être les introvertis qui
vont avoir très peu de pouvoir en
particulier le postulat de base de
démocratie délibérative ne résout
absolument pas le fait que le peuple ou
des citoyens tirés au hasard sont encore
pires qu'ignorant et irrationnel ça ne
change pas non plus les incentives des
médias et des politiciens de chercher à
les influencer en créant un maximum
d'hooliganisme politique et ça ne change
pas non plus le fait que ben moi j'ai
pas envie d'être tirés au hasard surtout
si je suis tiré au hasard pour débattre
d'un sujet qui ne m'intéresse pas alors
une solution pour résoudre quelques uns
de ces problèmes c'est d'ajouter des
séances de formation aux citoyens tirés
au hasard qui devons prendre une
décision sauf que pour donner ce genre
de formation il faut du coup des experts
qui vont donner la formation
les experts vont avoir un pouvoir
d'influencé et quelques parents tombent
déjà sur une sous une forme d'épi
stockera ci puisque d'une certaine
manière l'expert qui donnera la
formation du cours aura plus de pouvoir
que n'importe quel citoyen lambda qui
plus est il serait aussi bon dans ce
genre de situation de vérifier que les
citoyens qui ont suivi cette formation
ont bien suivi cette formation sont pas
justes constante et d'aller en cours et
de jouer sur un téléphone pendant le
cours et du coup pour pouvoir vérifier
que la formation a bien été faite va
sans doute il va devoir y avoir une
sorte d'examen qui risquent de
discriminer les gens qui étaient
intéressés par le sujet politique et qui
du coup ont bien suivi le cours des gens
qui ne s'y intéressaient pas donc encore
une fois on a une forme d'épi stockera
ci qui émergent
je ne le suis pas du tout content
recevoir de démocratie mais choqué
intéressant de voir que c'est une
certaine forme des pistes oak racing qui
serait implémenter et encore une fois
pour juger si c'est bien aussi c'est mal
je pense qu'il est très important de
voir les conséquences que cela implique
en particulier choc ya beaucoup de
théories qui sont faites autour de ce
principe de démocratie délibérative ou
participative tirage au sort aux
démocraties liquide et pas mal de
concepts autour de tout ça
qui suppose une certaine manière que les
gens vont se comporter de manière
rationnelle et informer autrement dit
pour reprendre les mots de john brennan
beaucoup de ces théories suppose que les
gens sont des espèces de vulcain c'est à
dire qu'ils sont capables de raisonner
de façon rationnelle et de s'informer de
chercher à prendre des bonnes décisions
et ainsi de suite
sauf qu'en pratique c'est pas du tout
comme ça que les gens se comportent et
vous pouvez voir dans beaucoup de
commentaires youtube
d'ailleurs je suis été très surpris
agréablement surpris les commentaires la
vidéo précédente eu énormément de
commentaires a finalement assez peu de
commentaires hooligans bien et gâte
mais dans beaucoup d'autres vidéos il
n'y a pas de censure de l'organisme
typiquement les commentaires c'est
souvent horrible j'ai bien peur que des
comportements similaires vont apparaître
et que finalement la délibération sera
pas du tout productive bref comme le
dirait des scènes rénale beaucoup de
théories de la démocratie suppose que
les citoyens se comportent en vulcain
mais en pratique les gens se comportent
ou bien aux beats ailleurs des gens qui
ne savent rien qui seront très ignorants
ou bien en louisiane c'est à dire les
gens qui vont combattre
irrationnellement les idées qui sont les
leurs et qu'il considère sacré au final
la question intéressante c'est sans
doute celle de pierre sans fin qui nous
demandent au final quelles décisions
doivent faire l'objet d'un processus
démocratique et surtout quelles
décisions ne doivent pas être influencée
par l'opinion démocratique et j'espère
que j'avais mais cette vidéo et que ça
nous permet d'avoir une meilleure idée
de ce qu'on entend par épi stockera si
les pistes au cra si c'est un système
tout fait tout comme finalement et
démocratie énormément de 22 la
démocratie c'est une question très
compliquée l'objectif de ces vidéos
c'est surtout montrer qu'il ya d'autres
façons de penser la manière dont on vit
en politique et que ses autres manières
on peut être de bien meilleures
conséquence que le principe démocratique
alors pour ceux qui voudraient sortir du
monde de la politique et revenir à des
trucs vraiment cool
matic et bien cette série est bientôt
finie ne reste plus que deux épisodes
qui sont beaucoup moins critique est
moins important notamment à la semaine
prochaine va le faire un truc un petit
peu plus artistique parce que ça donne
bien ce que ça donne et dans deux
semaines on va tous récapituler et
conclure cette série sur la démocratie
si vous avez aimez cette vidéo pensez à
la ligue et à la commenter à la partager
pensez à vous abonner pour ne pas
manquer futurs épisodes merci au type
heures pour leurs dons et j'espère que
vous serez là la prochaine fois ainsi si
la démocratie délibérative vise
l'émancipation politique il faudrait en
même temps pensé une émancipation
sociale et économique
faut-il encore pour cela à comprendre
les mécanismes divers domination pour ne
pas retomber dans un formalisme théorie